foreign
what's up Leanna
hi how's it going so good how about you
I'm doing well trying to keep my kids
for listening to the show a little bit
good for you you're a good parent you're
a good parent they they enjoy the peeing
stories though so it's always fun that's
my wife tells me my humor capped out at
about 11. so perfect
uh you're not dating in the metaverse
are you no no happily married
good in the real world you're married to
like a human
mechanics so he's very real world oh
very real world excellent excellent okay
so what's up Leanna how can I help
so I am my question was
um am I selfish for wanting to take a
trip by myself without my wonderful
husband in my
um kids
um a little back story so I have two
kids I have a four-year-old and an
almost two-year-old
so I'm kind of in the middle of it all
um I am a part-time realtor and a
part-time MLM consultant and I'm in
school full-time taking 17 credits right
now
um online
so there's not really a whole lot of
down time for me I feel like really the
only time I can get away is during the
very short deer hunting season that we
have here in Minnesota
um your deer hunting season is absurd by
the way
[Laughter]
mom so you know I feel selfish for
wanting to take a trip without them and
some comments my husband has made
sometimes makes me feel even more so
tell me what those comments are
um well it's mainly like he does this
dirt bike trip
and he's like oh it costs like hardly
nothing just the gas for the dirt bike
and and maybe some food so he's like I
don't really understand why you would
want to spend money on a trip for
yourself when we should be spending the
money on a trip for all of us as a
family
and so then I'm like okay why is it why
is it either or
that's what I don't understand either
um you know before his his knowledge or
thoughts were he couldn't keep me safe
and I grew up in a military family I can
keep myself plenty safe
um yeah yeah um yes the deer need to be
worried about you so let me I'll just
answer this directly absolutely not
in no way are you selfish I just listen
I just finished
um I just finished three months of what
I would call hell of of Riot book
writing hard it's just like getting up
at 5am going to work and then heading
off into a dark hole by yourself and
getting done at 10 or 11 at night it may
have been month after month on the road
riding in hotel rooms it's been chaos I
just hit send on the manuscript last
week
and
that weekend I got I mean on Wednesday I
got on a plane and flew to Utah to meet
up two great guys
um Dustin and Steve and I went with a
buddy here that I work with at Ramsey
and we went on a hunting trip in the
middle of nowhere Utah
and on the surface it could be I felt I
felt what you're feeling and felt a
little bit selfish
it was the most important thing I could
do because I had to go clear the cobwebs
so that I could come back and be present
otherwise my kids and my wife become
another task right they become just
another thing in order like I got to do
my classwork I gotta do this I gotta go
hug my kid I gotta go show up to the
school thing I got to make sure my
wife's happy
and they deserve more than to be part of
my checklist
right and so it's critical
that we get away and separate and I
absolutely love love when my wife goes
to hang out with her friends she comes
back renewed and refreshed and she's got
new thoughts and new ideas I love it
love it love it
um and it sucks because yeah right I
gotta do bedtimes and morning times and
breakfast to make sure people are
putting on deodorant and making lunches
I gotta do all that I don't like doing
that and
um but it's part of being in a
partnership right it's part of being
married
um I I I think going down the road of
but my trip cost this and why does your
trip that's Dangerous Ground that's
comparison man and that's just that's
just gonna melt uh melts of marriage
every time marriage can't be 50 50 like
that well you spent this much so I get
to spend this much I said it can't be
like that otherwise it just becomes this
tit for tapness forever and man you
can't build a relationship on that
right well and I feel like that's what
he saw growing up because his mom would
take trips and now she does trips with
her daughter-in-laws and then my
father-in-law would go on a canoe trip
in The Boundary Waters with the boys and
it'd be a very you know less costly than
what hers were but they'd be arguing
about it and just that's just what he
saw yeah I think it's I think it's
important to call that out this is what
we both this is what you saw growing up
this isn't how we're gonna do this
because the thing that brings you Joy is
I don't know what trip you want to go on
a cruise like getting away getting out
on the Open Water that's a thing and the
thing that brings you Joy is riding
motorbikes across the country I mean
across the state by the way motorbikes
are expensive and so maybe the trip
itself is inexpensive but all in like I
can do that I can have this really fancy
Sitka gear that I got good grief it's
like an Armani suit and I can have
really fancy like hunting equipment
and then I can be like hey my trip don't
cost nothing I'm just going out to sit
in the woods for a few few hours that's
ridiculous right right so my cost is
just all on the front end and my wife
may spend nothing ever ever and they
want to go on a cruise or go hang out
with their friends but dude I think
that's amazing it goes back to putting
your oxygen mask on first here's the
only time I'll call you out okay
is if you are going on this trip to run
away
hmm okay
um if you are out of capacity and you
feel like you have to escape them
one is running from a thing one is
running towards a thing and it can look
very similar but here's what happens if
you run from a thing you're going to get
a cabin somewhere with a couple of
girlfriends and you are going to end up
doing nothing
right and you're going to get frustrated
that you didn't fee that you showed up
with you you went with you back to your
house
right so I'm gonna go on a vacation for
a very specific reason I'm gonna go and
take five books and sit in a cabin for
three days and do absolutely nothing and
my goal is restoration or I came back
from my trip more exhausted than when I
left I right it was eight degrees
outside it was freezing we were hiking
through snow up mountains it was Madness
um so I came back more exhausted but my
goal wasn't to go get restoration my
goal was to go hit control delete right
right so I planned that going into it
okay yeah and I feel like restoration is
definitely needed maybe there's a little
bit of the Escape idea but more so just
because
2022 was a terrible year
um and I just need a break basically
what I do is I wake up in the morning
and immediately start going going doing
real estate things handling kids and and
making sure everything is good in the
house and then when everybody goes to
bed I'm up for three or four hours doing
school yeah yeah so some of that is some
of that is yeah yeah absolutely and some
of that seasonal right you are going to
graduate
um the real estate market is on a
dumpster fire right now and it will come
back right right so you're in a you're
in a wild season right now
more broadly speaking
I'm more concerned that once those
things level back out you're going to
find more stuff just to fill them
um my friend Ian Simkins he's a pastor
here in Nashville he said a line
recently that just melted me he said
if busyness is your drug rest will feel
like stress
okay and if you're creating a world that
is super busy all of the time on top of
the busyness of just being a mother of a
few young kids
you're going to cross the line the
graduation stage and you're going to
immediately feel that that void with
more crap
yeah I want you to build a life you
don't have to run away from
yeah and go away and have fun and enjoy
your life right go go on a trip and
um I'm not gonna lie my wife says I
don't vacation well with you sometimes I
need to go away by myself for three or
four days with some friends there's a
little piece of me that hurts my
feelings like I wish I was like I wish
she was like you make me calm and you
bring me restoration but I'm a little
bit not like that I I a little bit more
chaotic right and so yeah I wish I
wasn't I do I do I just am and so the
next best thing is I can honor her and
be super excited that she's going to
take care of herself and she's yeah
um getting restoration and all that kind
of stuff that makes sense yeah that
totally makes sense I appreciate it
thank you so much I got it so here's
your homework assignment okay homework
assignment is I want you
to get by yourself go get coffee I know
this is a tall order even if you got to
get up half an hour early okay you'll be
super tired
um have an extra coffee this one
particular morning and I want you to
write down
your needs
okay here's what I need in my house and
usually for a mom in your situation
I need help with the kids and I know my
husband's working really hard but it's
just not me in school when I go to
school we're both in school
and
it's not just I have three kids we have
three kids and I know he's working hard
and I still need some help and I need to
get three days so that I can go just
laugh and cut up with my girlfriends I
need three days so I can just go scare
off into space and whatever awesome and
if he comes back with
um well then I get my three day I your
response needs to be honey I'm not in
competition with you
yeah I'm not competing with you we're
not going to go back and forth we're not
on a teeter-totter here
what you need you you need and what I
need I need and I want to learn how to
say my needs out loud and us together to
figure out how we can both meet those
does that make sense yeah that makes
sense completely and I know that can be
a pipe dream for some folks I know
because I know that some husbands or
wives or whatever just I ain't doing
that
I'll tell you if you're listening and
your romantic partner your spouse comes
to you and says
look I
I need this or I really want to take a
trip with my girlfriends I want to take
a trip with my the guys
try it just once and say that's amazing
can we plan that can we plan the exit
like what the a couple of days before
you go can we plan the re-entry a couple
days after you get back can we play in
what that will look like so that we're
all on the same page and I could best
love and honor you as you come back as
you go right
um could we do that together that'd be
amazing
um try
it's practice just try it once and if
it's a disaster that's on me try once
being excited even if you gotta fake it
I'm all in I'm all in
go have your trip go have fun get away
you deserve you've been working really
hard I'll pick up some slack when you
get back
um
I'll be excited to see you try that
instead of what about me that's
expensive
man
give the gifts of uh support
try that